Simplifica y nos piden hacer una resta quieren que a 16x más 14 le restemos
3x cuadrada más x -9 ¿Muy bien? Esto es básicamente hacer una suma, solo que teniendo el cuidado
de que esté menos, primero tenemos que
distribuirlo ¿Si? Tenemos que distribuirlo en cada uno de estos términos.
Entonces hay que multiplicar primero por -1 o bien pensar como que estamos sumando el negativo.
Entonces déjame reescribir la expresión, para hacer eso el primero no cambia, es más le voy a quitar,
le voy a quitar el paréntesis, le voy a poner
16x más 14
y ahora sí debemos distribuir este signo -, déjame tomar otro color. Entonces primero va menos por este
3x cuadrada nos quedaría -3x cuadrada luego menos con este "x"
menos -1 por "x" es - "x" menos por más es menos, y finalmente este menos por este
- 9 nos queda igual a más 9, -1 por -9 es igual a más 9 ¿Muy bien? Aquí ya tenemos
desarrollado con el signo - ¿Verdad? Y ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es combinar los términos que tengan el mismo exponente,
empezando por el más alto para que quede en forma estándar.
Entonces creo que el exponente más alto es
cuadrado ¿Ajá? Es este de acá y nada más tenemos este término, déjame indicarlo con este color rojo.
Entonces únicamente tenemos este término de acá que nos quedaría, lo ponemos por acá
-3x al cuadrado ¿Muy bien? Ahora vamos con los términos que tienen "x" a la 1
como este 16x y este -"x" los voy a indicar en color rosa, serían eso no es rosa.
Sería este de acá 16x - "x" ¿Cuánto nos quedaría? Pues 16 -1
16 -1 es igual a 15 entonces sería más
15x y finalmente tenemos que combinar los términos constantes que sería, este de acá el 14 y este de acá el 9
9 más 14 es 23 entonces aquí le ponemos más 23
y terminamos. Simplificando esta expresión nos queda -3x cuadrada más 15x más 23.